going to show you exactly how I keep my
dry skin nice and hydrated throughout my
13 hour flight right after cleansing my
face I'm starting off with my hyaluronic
acid serum which is the number one
hydrating ingredient in my skincare
routine next I'm moving on to vitamin C
serum which is going to give me that
glow brighten up my complexion and even
out my skin tone seriously just look at
how plump and hydrated my skin looks
immediately after applying next I'm
going to use my go-to gouachita stone to
do a little face massage to kind of like
de-puff my face and speaking of
puffiness I absolutely could not skip
applying a de-puffing eye cream mine has
caffeine in it which is going to help
relieve water retention which is exactly
what I need now on to the most important
part the moisturizer you absolutely need
to lock in all that good moisture
otherwise although serums would have
been for nothing oh and I definitely
could not forget about the lips so just
applying my favorite lip balm but that's
it